la primera parada del viaje del
candidato demócrata joe biden a
wisconsin en la ciudad de milwaukee allí
se reunió con la familia del
afroamericano jeyko plate quien quedó
paralizado luego de que un agente de
disparar a siete veces a la espalda y
posteriormente se desplazó hasta que
noche ciudad de residencia de blake y
nuevo epicentro de las protestas contra
el racismo y sostuvo un encuentro con la
comunidad lo que afirmó el presidente
expuso algo a lo que no se le ha
prestado suficiente atención que el
racismo oculto que está
institucionalizado en eeuu aún existe y
en sí y ha existido por cuatrocientos
años la visita del candidato fue
ampliamente comparada con la del
presidente de trump quien estuvo en que
no es este martes pero no mencionó a
blake y sólo mostró apoyo a locales
comerciales afectados durante los
disturbios en los que algunas veces
terminan las protestas
el mandatario calificó en las
manifestaciones de terrorismo interno
este miércoles trump viajó a carolina
del norte allí pidió a sus simpatizantes
que voten dos veces en las elecciones de
noviembre
permítanles votar por correo y luego
presencialmente si los sistemas son tan
buenos como dicen entonces no les
permitirán votar en las próximas semanas
el mandatario se ha dedicado a crear
desconfianza en el sistema electoral y
se ha ponderado como el único candidato
capaz de mantener la ley y el orden en
el país la favorabilidad de tomb se
encuentra en jaque por la crisis del cob
y 19 y por el manejo de las protestas
anti racismo de abuso policial
precisamente este miércoles se conoció
un nuevo caso en washington en el que un
policía le disparó a un afroamericano de
18 años quitándole la vida asimismo se
hizo público el caso de daniel clip un
hombre afro de 41 años que falleció
después de que agentes de la policía de
rochester lo detuvieron y le presionarán
la cabeza contra el pavimento los hechos
ocurrieron en marzo